[Musique]
avant
les cendres
nul plantes ne leur survie près d'un
volcan actif
[Musique]
presque tous les animaux fui ce chaos
quand ils le peuvent encore
[Musique]
pourtant d'autres prospère là où tout
semble devoir mourir
voici leur histoire
[Musique]
il était une fois et il sera encore de
nombreuses fois un drame
[Musique]
un volcan est en éruption
obligeant ce papillon géant a quitté son
île natale
il part face au vent pour des horizons
lointains est incertain
[Musique]
nous sommes au nord de l'australie au
bout d'une île appelée nouvelle bretagne
où une baisse profonde abrite la ville
de ras bol
ce golf et une caldeira une vaste
dépression volcanique évasées en son
centre est flanqué de petits cônes
à la fin du xxème siècle ce volcan
émettait les mêmes signes annonciateurs
aujourd'hui le quart car à quelques
centaines de kilomètres
quand le volcan sommeil ces forêts sont
des havres paisible où dorment tous le
jours des renards volants
lourdement suspendu à leurs branches
comme les papas et dont ils sont si
friands
il ya toujours une faille ou une
échancrure part au filtre la fièvre du
volcan avant son explosion
les végétaux river à la poudrière
périront de mort lente brûlé par ses
fumerolles sulfuré asidcom du vinaigre
entre 1971 et 1994 la baie de rabot la
subit quotidiennement plusieurs séismes
elle s'est même soulever de quelques
dizaines de centimètres sous la pression
des gaz et des roches en fusion
accumulés dans le sous sol
mais rien ne transparaissait dans
surface
jusqu'à ce matin du 19 septembre
[Musique]
les autochtones appellent ce cône le tas
pour vour ce qui signifie nid de frelons
poussé par les alizés les frelons
incandescent et surtout les cendres
chaudes se dirigent vers ras bol et ses
cent mille habitants
[Musique]
les hommes et presque tous les animaux
se sauve juste à temps seuls restent les
renards volants
leurs narines filtre les plus gros
fragment de cendres c'est tout juste
s'ils sont incommodés pourquoi partir et
il
la nuit réponses
faisant apparaître les danger invisible
au grand jour
[Musique]
avec la chair des fruits les renards
volants à valdes à présent de la cendre
les particules de métaux toxique et
corrosif s'infiltre dans leur système
digestif
prix de violents brûlures d'estomac il
fuit en grande volée ce havre devenue un
enfer
[Musique]
une fois en altitude les cendres du tas
pour vour se chargent d'eau
refroidissent puis retombe couvrant
toute la végétation d'un linceul grille
plus de soleil plus de photosynthèse
c'est fatal
il ya aussi ce poison que crache le
dragon le soufre
dans l'atmosphère le gaz mortel se
condense en acide sulfurique
des pluies corrosive achève de calciner
les végétaux
c'est dans ce désert insolite que nous
allons suivre les destins croisés de
quatre animaux extraordinaires
[Musique]
la chenille de l'ornithoptère
ces plantes préférées dépérissent
lentement le même sort l'attend si elle
reste là
dans l'impossibilité de partir ce
crustacé est contraint de s'adapter
c'est un bernard l'hermite terrestre
il y a encore celui que les volcans en
éruption attire
un rapace
le milan sacré repères plus facilement
ses proies sur des terres brûlées
[Musique]
enfin dans la longue histoire de la vie
sur terre la sélection naturelle a
retenu un animal qui ne pourrait exister
sans les volcans il s'agit d'un volatile
aux grands pieds un méga pod pour lui
l'éruption sonne l'heure d'une communion
avec les cendres
mais
[Musique]
oh
et
on
[Musique]
m
les méga pod au lieu de couver eux mêmes
leur eux utilisent des sources de
chaleur naturelle
seules les femelles les poules ont
quitté les forêts des îles voisines
pressé de confier leur progéniture ou à
bourbourg et assez couveuse chauffé par
le sol
elle arpente le terrain en quête de la
température idéale
35°
leurs pattes aussi grande soit elle sont
peu sensibles c'est une glande dans le
gosier qui leur indique les zones les
plus propices un thermomètre naturel
précis au degré près
cette poule est arrivé bien après les
autres les meilleurs emplacements sont
déjà occupées par des concerts plus
diligente
certaines ont d'ores et déjà déposé leur
offre en bonne place la retardataire
devrait se mettre à creuser elle aussi
mais elle semble envisager une solution
plus radicale
ne pourraient-elles s'approprier une
couveuse tout fait
[Musique]
la propriétaire refuse de se laisser
déloger et renvoie la fraudeuse à son
devoir aménager sa couveuse à la force
de ses ergots
chaque année depuis le réveil du tas
pour vous plus de cent mille oeufs sont
ainsi confié aux bons soins des cendres
pour la plupart des êtres vivants la vie
est éprouvante sur ses terres dévastées
les animaux marins en revanche sont à
peine affecté par les humeurs du tas
bourbourg car les courants renouvelle
sans cesse l'eau du golfe de ras bol
le matin au retour de ces chasse
nocturne une famille de dauphin se
tenait là long bec vient se détendre au
large du volcan
sur la presqu'île le volcan et les
intempéries font rage sans pour autant
détruire à tout jamais
ainsi la cendre asphyxie les plantes
tout en délivrant des minéraux qui
fertilisent le sol le volcan vient il à
s'apaiser que les plantes et les
végétariens prospère de nouveau
entre deux pluie de cendres la vie
patton
[Musique]
cette chenille dans et aubeterre a eu le
temps de se nourrir à satiété pendant
une accalmie
elle est sur le point d'entamer sa
métamorphose à l'abri des prochaines
colère du tas bourbourg
[Musique]
la transformation demande une semaine
environ
les organes de la chrysalide se liquéfie
avant d'être prodigieusement remodelé et
replacé par les subtiles à tous et à
tour du papillon
[Musique]
la voici papillon et presque oiseaux par
son envergure proche de celle du merle
d'où son nom courant le papillon à ailes
d'oiseaux acl jaune on reconnaît une
femelle
elle aura besoin d'une journée encore
pour sécher se déployer entièrement
permettre à sa vue de s'ajuster avec ses
yeux à facettes l'ornithoptère détecte
plusieurs centaines d' images par
seconde quand nous n'en voyons que 25
voici par exemple comment elle perçoit
le vol de ce frelon
comme au ralenti
pour les fourmis un papillon fraîchement
éclos est une providentielle buvette où
l'on savoure un hectare de protéines des
résidus de la nymphe aux
chasses et de la buvette cette fourmi
atterri chez un sinistre fossoyeur
le mystérieux tendeur de pièges et la
larve d'insecte éphémère le four
millions
la cendre du volcan cimente la terre
végétale et permet au four millions de
creuser des cratères si profond que peu
de fourmies en réchappe
[Musique]
celle ci a eu beaucoup de chance
une journée après la nymphe hausse du
papillon le temps est radieux excepté
sous le vent du cratère dans l'air sec
le panache s'élève sans ce condensé et
puis rencontre les vents d'altitude qui
répandent ces cendres à 600 km à la
ronde
les nuages volcaniques masquer la
lumière solaire notamment les
ultraviolets de haute fréquence ses
rayons imperceptible à l'oeil humain
sont indispensables aux papillons sans
eux sa vue est tronqué
les basses fréquences solaire qui inclut
la gamme des rouges se trouve filtré
elle aussi par le nuage aux yeux de ce
papillon jaune les fleurs d'hibiscus
dont ils aspirent habituellement le
nectar n'apparaissent plus dans le décor
sans avoir pu se nourrir la femelle
ornithoptère doit s'en allait quitter ce
monde incertain pour retrouver la
lumière pure mais avec ses ailes souple
elle ne saurait voler comme un oiseau
tout juste peut-être monter ou descendre
le lit du vent
pour sortir de ce nuage nocifs elle se
dirige vers sa source le cratère du
tabou rebours toujours en remontant
ouvre
[Musique]
au pied du nid de frelons les cendres
dispersées par le vent tu les cocotiers
cette récolte précoce arrangera certains
charognards
[Musique]
grâce à ses antennes le bernard
l'hermite terrestre détecte les
particules humide émises par la chaire
[Musique]
à ras bol ont dit que la lune influe sur
l'activité du tabou rebours comme elles
commandent les marais
les marais elles ont peu d'influencé sur
la vie du bernard l'hermite seules les
femelles en sont tributaires au moment
de donner la vie
mais la mer est désormais très loin au
bout d'un désert de cendres et de soufre
[Musique]
on
les oeufs sont camouflées sous la
coquille un millier de futurs crabes que
la femelle va livrer à l'océan
c'est sous l'auvent de cette story
qu'elle choisit d'abandonner sa
progéniture sur le territoire des
poissons clowns et des anémones
au premier contact avec l'eau de mer les
eux deviennent larvée se mêlent aux au
plancton cette nuée de trois minuscules
en libre service dans l'océan
[Musique]
ouh
où
en
[Musique]
non
moi
les larves qui n'auront pas été dévorés
dès leurs premiers instants dériveront
au gré des courants grandiront
trouveront un jour une coquille déserte
à squatter seul 1 % d'entre elles
accompliront cet exploit
malgré tout d'îles en îles et bernard
l'hermite terrestres ont ainsi colonisé
l'océan pacifique tropical
[Musique]
des luxuriante forêt entourant le tas
bourbourg il ne reste qu'un tapis de
cendres hérissée de squelette
autant de perchoir à la disposition des
milan sacré
[Musique]
ce mâle a choisi pour observatoire un
tulipier du gabon où les vents dominants
lui épargne de justesse les désagréments
du panache
avec sa vue huit fois plus puissante que
la nôtre et son louis pointus ils
identifient d'emblée l'intrus qui
s'approche
une femelle
mais
il
[Musique]
le couple s'est installé au milieu d'une
colonie de ce tournoi chanteur et pas
seulement chanteur brailleurs
chapardeurs est jaloux de leur
territoire
[Musique]
ce
les milans résister aux agressions et
commencer à construire leur nid
mais pour parer aux attaques des ce
tourne ou à leur larcin il faudra
toujours qu'un des deux parents montent
la garde
[Musique]
au vent du panache la lumière
ultraviolette brillera jusqu'au coucher
du soleil
d'ici là la femelle papillon doit
repérer une terre d'asile
sinon elle mourra noyer agen mais l'oeil
scrutateur
elle entame une périlleuse odyssée
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
m
et
les ornithoptère ont la force de
parcourir plus de 200 kilomètres par
jour
on retrouve ces ulysse jusqu'au littoral
de la papouasie et du nord de
l'australie ils sont particulièrement
nombreux à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de ras bol sur l'île de man
toutes sortes de navigateurs errants
aborde les îles côtières
madame accueille notamment des
balbuzards
sentinelle toujours aux aguets
[Musique]
le balbuzard ne s'intéresse peu
heureusement qu aux poissons
pendant qu'il pêche l'ornithoptère
couvrira la courte distance qui le
sépare de l'île verdoyante
vous
on
[Musique]
non
avant
voici à quoi ressemblaient les forêts
tropicales de la baie de la baule avant
l'éruption du tas vous revoir
le tableau actuel un camaïeu de gris le
tabouret d'humeur changeante à présent
son magma devenu visqueux obstruant le
cratère en sous sol la pression monte
jusqu'à la rupture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'eau les retombées sont sans
importance bien vite absorbée par le
grand brassage de l'océan
à l'intérieur des terres on attendra la
venue d'un orage tropical pur se lave et
des cendres
ces pluies érode le sol au pied du
tabouret creuse le lit de ruisseaux
éphémère où s'aventurent parfois des
filles de neptune
des anguilles marbré
une grande presque deux mètres sont trop
lourdes pour se hisser sur la berge
l'instinct du chasseur les conduit
cependant à se surpasser pour grimper il
suffit d'un peu d'élan
il en faut un peu plus pour faire courir
un bernard l'ermite
[Musique]
bravant orages scories et cendres les
poules venue de forêt lointaine élabore
un second sauf qu'elle déposera là
encore au pied de la lettre ce sacré
[Musique]
oh
parfois le nid envoie ces frelons
incandescent dans tous les sens les plus
gros ont la taille d'un autobus
avec un bon sens de l'observation et un
minimum d'expérience balistique on peut
éviter d'être écrasés
depuis que le tabou rebours s'est
réveillé vingt mille poules viennent
pondre tous les ans autour du cratère
elles savent proposer avec les humeurs
du volcan la preuve en est que l'on n'a
jamais recensée la moindre poule tués
par une bombe volcaniques elles sont
bien trop alerte
[Musique]
il arrive que sous l'effet du stress
elles abandonnent leurs oeuvres sur le
sol sans prendre la peine de lui
aménager un creux
la chaleur solaire emmagasinée par les
cendres pourraient suffire à assurer son
incubation mais elles doivent affronter
un prédateur venu tout droit de la
préhistoire
le var ont dû pacifique
ses yeux ne discerne que les objets en
mouvement pour tout ce qui est immobile
il doit suivre l'invisible et sinueux
chemin des odeurs
c'est sa langue fourchue qui détecte le
parfum des oeufs fraîchement pondus
il a aussi deux organes olfactif au bout
de son museau qui l'aident à trouver la
position exacte d'un objet odorant par
triangulation
l'offre de mega pod contient trois fois
plus de jaune que celui d'une poule
domestique un concentré de vitamines et
de sels minéraux
au bout du compte ces pertes ponctuelles
sont insignifiantes pour les populations
de mega pod
les poules repartent à présent se
nourrir en forêt en l'espace d'un mois
chacune aura pont du 2e dans les
chaudrons du havre ou
à certains endroits ses chaudrons des
gaz du dioxyde de soufre coïncidence ou
farce de la nature ce gaz empeste l'oeuf
pourri
plus les ruisseaux éphémère s'évapore
plus ils sont saturés d'acide sulfurique
et toxiques pour qui voudrait s'y
désaltérer
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans la zone atteinte par ces
fusées brûlante que le volcan fait le
plus de victimes
[Musique]
dans ce déluge de bombes les milan sacré
peuvent se permettre de chasser leurs
vues pénétrantes se double d'un large
champ de vision d'un même regard ils
perçoivent un minuscule cadavres au sol
et les déjections du monstre grille
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
il serait tout de même risqué de
s'attarder ici trop longtemps le temps
de la digestion il plane en bloquant ses
ailes
[Musique]
loin de cet enfer l'île de man à mme le
paradis choisi par la femelle papillon
elle a été aperçue par un mâle de son
espèce il porte au zèle des écailles que
font chatoyer les rayons ultraviolets la
femelle n'y sera sans doute pas
indifférente mais pour la conquérir
vraiment le mal doit voler près d'elle
et diffuser un parfum à base de
phéromones l'invitant à la population
[Musique]
e
lui
on rêve
[Musique]
qui veut
tous
cette femelle ne semble pas vouloir
s'accoupler finalement c'est bien normal
elle a déjà été fécondés et ne
papillonne que pour chercher un endroit
où pondre
elle déposera ses quelques 200 jeux sur
sa liane fétiche cette plante s'appelle
l'aristo loge un nom prédestiné
d'origine grecque signifiant la
meilleure pour la naissance
[Musique]
se gorger d'aristo loges et seulement
d'aristo logent les chenilles dans les
docteurs s'y applique en vue de leur
métamorphose
la plante contient des alcaloïdes
toxiques bénin pour les chenilles mais
dangereux pour ceux qui seraient tentés
de les dévorer comme ce grand pigeon des
plus élégants le gura de victoria
il est normalement frugivores
[Musique]
prend t-il la chenille pour un fruit
exotique
le poison attaque directement l'adn et
provoque des cancers
la sélection naturelle sera limité ces
accidents elle ne retient que les
lignées de gourin ayant appris à se
méfier de ces chenilles
à l'horizon le tabouret d'humeur moins
sombre il a coiffé son panache blanc
blanc comme la vapeur d'eau entre deux
éruptions la pression au sud dans la
chambre magmatique de l'eau de mer
réchauffer s'infiltre par le sol et
s'évapore par toutes les failles
possibles
[Musique]
l'accalmie un vide se poussent à deux
mégapoles d'acquitter sa couveuse
artisanale il est absolument seul au
monde aucun soin parental aucun
apprentissage de l'ue sera prodigué un
cas unique chez les oiseaux et l'énergie
ne lui manque pas il l'a puisée dans le
jaune très nourrissant qui remplissait
sa coquille il peut même voler dès le
premier jour
[Musique]
la seule chose qui rapproche les mégapot
dé milan sacré et le jeu routinier du
prédateur et de la proie
à l'opposé des mégapoles les mille ans
ont des parents attentifs ils
communiquaient se partagent
équitablement les tâches l'un protégeant
le nid contre laisse tourner voleurs
quand l'autre va chasser
[Musique]
oui
les mégaphones ne doivent leur survie
qu'à la chaleur des cendres y voir
proliférer autour des volcans de
papouasie nouvelle guinée nous rappelle
que le volcanisme a forgé l'histoire de
la vie sur terre
[Musique]
voilà seize ans que le tas vous recrache
ces frelons de braise les animaux ont eu
le temps d'établir alentours leurs
repères ce couple de milan revient
chaque année dans le même nid pour
élever un ou deux aiglons
pour imaginer quels aspects aura demain
le tabou revault il suffit de traverser
la baie de la baule là se dresse le
vulcain qui s'est passagèrement réveillé
en 1994 les bienfaits des cendres ont
rendu à la végétation sa luxuriance
d'autrefois
la papouasie est une terre de volcans
quand l'un c'est un l'autre s'éveille
maintenant c'est au tour du madame de
mettre sur les routes de l'exode un
voyageur éphémère
[Musique]